Michael Wilbon co-hosts a pardon the
interruption joining us on the program
good morning Michael how are you doing
I'm fired up are you what happened I've
been watched it can peak off and on at
you this morning what are you so fired
up about the 18 playoff that I want to
come up with because these comp we got
to get rid of conference title games and
this way I get the the five power
conference winners and then I get three
at-large and now I have some interesting
match imagine if you had oh hi oh State
Notre Dame this weekend Mike yeah yeah
Dan okay I was always been eight playoff
Kyle I mean 20 years ago when it wasn't
you know nobody would give it any sort
of consideration people were screaming
at me about the sanctity or regular
college football season nothing stop you
need to playoff and of course you know
we've got one now if you could tell me
we could go back to regular 10 team
content team caucus and you know I don't
have to have Maryland and Rutgers in
mind that's a pathetic sets me off if we
could go back to that and there would be
more than five of them then it'd be like
a power what seven or something then I'd
be okay for that and now again I was an
eighth guy I'm not right now cuz I don't
think there's eight out there were these
not gonna get my attention and it just
causes for it I'm fine with getting rid
of the conference tournaments to do it
if you could tell me we had the
conference landscape of the late 1990
that we don't yeah but I'd still like to
get Central Florida in you know I'm with
that Central Florida okay I can't say I
think they should get in now no I can't
I can't say that particularly of Georgia
beat Alabama on Saturday but I just
think that I don't see enough other
teams out there that I want to schedule
my life around
in early January or even late December
to see them in another round of stuff
not yet maybe that will develop and yeah
I think that that is preferable to me to
these fourteen team or 16 team
conferences I hate that set up but you
also have a college season that it has
been kind of lackluster it's boring you
know it's
lack of upsets I mean I always think
somebody's gonna lose eyes went right
through Saturday thinking I don't know
I'm not gonna say I thought there was
going to be a specific game but you know
let's face it we just haven't had that
many undefeated lately and and this year
you know they have them bunched at the
top I think is what I agree with you
this has not been a spectacularly
interesting college football season what
is bothering you right now you know what
I don't think anything is I mean if I
look across sort of the bigger landscape
I don't see it I mean you know I can get
exercised over one and done but I get
exercised over that in a way that no one
like you've got to have a hot take if
you're going to have this job angry
someone is I just think right now you
know the college football season has
been great but my team has had a run so
therefore I you know I'm not wired I'm
not as wired on college football I often
am because I'm too complacent cuz my
team's been good although god help us
Saturday in Indiana against the last day
ok I got one for you here if I said the
more dangerous team in the playoffs the
Bears are the Texans wow that's pretty
good
I mean that's legit I mean the Texans
I thought the Texas might drop one last
night I thought that in Division these
division games are closer and tougher
and harder to win yeah and though they
were at home and Tennessee obviously has
some you know it feels a little bit
going on having beaten the Patriots I
I'm biased here Dan you know in a way I
think the Bears
I think the Bears are gonna crush Green
Bay and so this notion at Green Bay is
gonna come and never say that there's
only one time in my life is it the
Cardinals and the Packers just exist to
haunt me
and I thought in 2015 when it comes to
the Cardinals after finally getting the
playoffs as I said out loud I first did
it only didn't sit on the air the club's
gonna crush the cockles in this series I
never believed that I believe it
happened believed the Bears are going to
pop the Packers at December 16 I think
that's gonna put the Packers out of
their misery this year and they got
misery I mean that did the Packers look
they don't
everybody talks about running the table
and I've done it before yeah when they
did it before they weren't starting off
looking as I don't know discombobulated
as they are now so I think I think I
think the Bears will win that division
and and and I think this is the year to
do it because there are there's even
though they've been flexed twice and
people are talking about them there's
less in the way of expectations this
year there's going to be coming up why
is it when the Packers win Aaron Rodgers
win when the Packers lose Mike McCarthy
loses I mean Mike McCarthy it just looks
like it's come to a close
a part of this goes back to to me Dan
when they fired the quarterback coach
and didn't tell Aaron Rodgers
I mean basically they were saying to
Aaron Rodgers like they stayed up every
other position player in the sport of
pro football you don't matter that much
and as we know there's one position in
football and pro football you you can't
pander it that way
and that guy you can't handle that well
he's too independent a thinker Aaron
Rodgers is not going to be suppressed
because I'm a coach and I've got the
authority this is football give it to
him about that you know I was I still
Aaron Rodgers on the sidelines at a
Warriors game two years ago in the
playoffs you know during a you know
championship run and Aaron Rodgers was
sitting there watching and he's I said I
know I bet you put up some points in
your day we started talking about his
basketball career and how he wanted to
play basketball 1 or 2 play aspire to
play pro basketball but you know he
didn't get the offers that we're gonna
put him in that position and he
understood that but here's what he said
to me he said you know what this means
basketball he's standing there looking
at Steph Curry warm up this is what I
love and to me that was a revelation and
part of it I think if he gets older is
because the business of it is what may
turn him off that his car is GM or
whoever fired the quarterback coach
didn't even have doing the courtesy of a
phone call when he works most closely
with him yeah
that all of that contributes to what
we're seeing I mean it seems hard I
can't imagine unless they go to the
Super Bowl I don't know at least the AFC
title game that McCarthy and Aaron
Rodgers are gonna be working together
next year do you whether you see this
going on no no I thought a couple of
weeks ago you can just look at the
disconnect on the sidelines yeah if I
watch Brees and Sean Payton like if you
watch you know Brady's not talking to
Bella check and you'd be talking to you
know Josh McDaniels but if you're not
talking to your coach your head coach or
your offensive coordinator I don't know
it just feels like they're looking at
this go away what you know if we go back
this is in sideline footage from like I
don't know six years ago what are we
going to be different I think it would
be but I don't understand that
Rodgers it has the final say so whenever
they there may be a lack of imagination
and creativity with the Packers in Mike
McCarthy but it feels like Aaron Rodgers
should be able to say I'm gonna do it
this way or this is this is what we're
doing here yes he doesn't he doesn't
even he doesn't have it doesn't feel I
don't know comfortable doing it either
way what's not working to me is more
profound than just you know the Packers
aren't creative I think it's I think
it's more than that I think there's a
there's a there's not just disconnected
there's some I don't know what what's
the word maybe was that minute that I'm
not close enough to that situation to
understand all the nuances of it but I
really do believe it started with the
changing of personnel and change and not
just I don't mean on field but on
sideline in that box on Sundays of
things that make Aaron Rodgers feel
empowered I think that those things at
least one of them and maybe more were
taken away from him and that's gonna be
that he's Michael Wilbon co-host of
pardon the interruption with mr. Tony
joining us Dan Patrick show are you
still interested in the Lakers yes like
what do you what are you watching for
right now well okay so I'm doing
something right now I've never really
done was so I'd like the first two weeks
I went crazy watching everything yeah
and then it's like okay the season
started to see the star so
not God the rimbor one was too early and
now October 13 no I mean or 18
that's crazy early so you know I didn't
check out but I'm not watching
obsessively that talked about this with
Mike D'Antoni last night here in
Washington before that game against the
Wizards just about like having no well
having this Jordan preseason in the Pro
Football Steve Young talks all the time
now about very eloquently about how the
first four games of the regular season
are like the like like preseason used to
be and and everybody understands why
they've cut preseason in every sport I
get it except baseball I get it but in
in basketball guys were now I had a two
players tell me last night that they
were not they thought they were in great
shape condition to come to camp and star
but they weren't in basketball shape
when it started and they're just getting
there like last few games so I think you
can get a bit of a false read I'm
looking to see what the Lakers just game
the game how they play and this is it's
funny to me how and I'm sure both of our
shows have been guilted in some way you
know they win four games in a row they
win five of six you said the Lakers turn
the corner another hadn't even gotten to
the corner there at the corner there
down the street so I'm just looking to
see how different guys play together
am I seeing Ingram like progress as
those of us who fit Attica Lee watch
this stuff think that he's supposed to
or will you know where's where's Lonzo
ball so this individual nerdy stuff
maybe but I'm I'm still interested in
the Lakers but I'm gonna get the point
about checking out a little bit of the
season now I'm gonna be really excited
about watching it in Jay after starting
Christmas Day yeah I got you know six
weeks no how many weeks we have it we
got a month you had a month ago to
Christmas Day yeah I don't have a
referendum on the Lakers everyday on
this show after every game and you know
that's what everybody wants to know like
you know where are they now and I said
you know what check with me in January
we'll get a better sense of you know if
they've they've added subtracted you
know how these younger players are
progressing maturity level those kind of
things but for the time being
oh wait I'm saying to people hey slow
down
yes you know it's such a long season and
I think the people who haven't been
around it for the in and out the back
and forth the up and down you know they
want a sprint you know and that and it's
not that sport there's one sprint sport
and in professional level in the NFL
it's such a long season that I'm like
you
Christmas Day is the start of a new
interest I don't I'm not gonna really
get there until like I'm like you mid
January probably I also brought this up
a couple of weeks ago with Kevin Durant
I think it's a foregone conclusion he's
not back with the team this is even
before he and draymond had their moment
there or moments but I I wonder when you
know Stephen a Smith said well the two
destinations are the Knicks of the
Lakers
I see more of the Knicks with Kevin
Durant then I do the Lakers because I
wonder if Kevin Durant wants to help
LeBron get more titles I agree with that
I'm with you on that I just I don't see
that as much as others do now Kanter and
handle New York Mike no I mean I know
Kevin a little bit I mean you know I
live where he lived and grew up and he
is you know it's so funny Dan he's like
a different person in the summer when he
comes home and he's he's built libraries
I mean he's done so much stuff here in
the community outside of Washington
where he lives and I've been around him
for stuff that he asked me to come out
and toast some of his chair charitable
events I've done that and it's like a
different guy and I understand that the
pressure of this moves most people but
the pressure of New York is different in
a way that even though he grew up you
know a four hour drive or train ride
away
I don't know I mean I don't know how you
I don't I don't know that you can and
that you can correctly anticipate it
that the volume is what it is if the
penetration is what it is the depth of
it and if he I mean you know San
Francisco is one of the easier places to
exist I mean I think Oklahoma City of
course is much easier to either one of
them except you got to deal with Russell
Westbrook on a daily basis but if you're
left if you left to hear the
counter-argument to
to us this some short Steven they was
saying if you'd left to go to Golden
State to sort of join to link up to hook
up with the championship outfit you know
why would he do it and the LeBron part
of it is what I agree with you on but
you know these relationships change they
thaw they evolve that can be something
organic where guys who didn't like each
other
begin to like each other as they get
older I said wait a minute we can do
this for common good I wouldn't want to
see that but doesn't Durant want to
stand out as the best player in the game
I don't know I I think he probably
thinks he's already done that by winning
the MVP did anyone the MVP of this of
the regular season bishop series oh yeah
yeah I think he's won one at twice I
think he's won yeah so that doesn't make
you the best player in the game yeah i
but you know a lot of people think
they're the best at something in the
game now and they aren't and you and I
would probably be on the same side of
most of these arguments having seen
offensive Dan we're old enough to have
seen three-quarters of the history of
pro basketball at the NBA yeah and they
have it and unlike people who study the
history in the generation before them on
the look I mean I had enough
conversation and I know you did too with
Michael Jordan who would literally just
sit people down and pick their brains
until he had no more questions about the
history of the game magic would go on
the road a date early to talk to a coach
would find Wes Unseld and talk to him
about what happened against you know
Willis Reed and the guys who played you
know Bob Lanier and Rick berry though
that guys don't do that anymore LeBron
does I don't know that that happens as
much anymore I don't know that there's
that sort of reverence that leads to
serious introspection it just becomes
wrong I'm the greatest player in the era
of the you know Sports Center so
therefore I mean you know it's not that
sort of introspection so I don't know
that he wants to do that I would you I
don't want to see him on the Lakers am i
but I don't know I keep hearing other
players people talk about that with
Anthony Davis yeah you know he's got to
go to the Lakers I mean you know the
Lakers
have anything for five years and
everybody's got to go there so I'm
interested in them this year I know the
speculation on those two players
specifically will be obsessive as soon
as we get back the all-star break
if the rosters are set but yeah Durant
in New York I don't know that either
there's other teams only the I mean New
York in LA and nobody ever goes to New
York who goes to the Knicks but who
actually goes there on their own maybe
maybe a chance it maybe it changes maybe
maybe that week we got a lot of time to
speculate tell mister tell mr. Tony we
settle oh and good luck to your bears
thank you buddy
that's a Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]